la lino la liaison inter régionale nord
ouest a mis près d'un demi-siècle à voir
le jour c'est à dire qu'elle était
attendue par les dijonnais bien sûr mais
aussi par toutes les personnes qui
travaillent sur dijon le 10 février 2014
la lino ouvrait enfin ses portes aux
automobilistes dans une ambiance vous
allez le voir le foriic ils étaient
nombreux en effet à vouloir étrenner
cette toute nouvelle route comme mouly
placé en pole position
j'étais en troisième position les gens
peuvent envoyer des patients donc ouais
je retrouve en première position à 11h08
la barrière s'ouvre enfin ça y est la
lino est en fonction dans le sens
plombières toison d'or comme tous les
jours lice vincent quitte son domicile à
dre direction dijon où elle travaille
autoroute à 38,8 lino 38 km au total
la routine depuis près de trois ans
l'isu fait ce trajet là tous les matins
en fait la lino a changé votre vie wes a
changé la vie au niveau de notre
domicile ça réduit drastiquement les
tanks transport pour se rendre du côté
du côté nord de dijon
on n'a pas hésité à s'éloigner un petit
peu de dijon pour pour être être à la
campagne et ça ouvert un spectre au
moment des recherches de travail
vraiment beaucoup plus large
la route permet de relier la 38 au
quartier nord de dijon en six minutes
là où avant il en fallait 20 mai aux
heures de pointe
les choses sont bien différentes là
c'est l'arrivée sur le rond-point de
fontaine-lès-dijon c'est comme ça tous
les matches c'est comme ça tous les
matins on arrive en effectivement sur le
rond-point de fontaine on est on est à
l'arrêt pour à peu près 6 8 minutes pour
parcourir l'équivalent je sais pas de
600 700 m ça c'est le fait en fait qu'on
passe de voie à une seule voix on a le
rétrécissement d'ergo lot ce soir
rebelote le soir dans l'autre sens tout
à fait oui c'est très courageusement que
vous laisser dans les embouteillages
je remercie
des véhicules toujours plus de véhicules
la lino une affaire qui roule
via cinq ans des services de l'état
prévoyait une fréquentation de 15000 à
25 mille unités jour d'aujourd'hui la
direction interdépartementale des routes
qui exploite la liaison nord est formel
on est bien au-delà
c'est une infrastructure qui a connu un
surcroît de trafic important ces
dernières années de l'ordre de 20%
depuis sa mise en service est ce qu'il
ya des accidents sur cette route
la lino n'est pas plus accidentogènes
que le reste du réseau que nous
exploitons en côte d'or on a des
accidents qui sont essentiellement des
accidents matériels et au niveau du
tunnel de talent et fonctionnement des
problématiques de pannes de véhicules
trafic soutenu sur la lino et la rocade
mais qu'en est il de la circulation en
ville avant la lino c'est grande avenue
périphérique était souvent saturé
notamment à côté poids lourds en transit
aujourd'hui l'ambiance est toute autre
selon dijon métropole le trafic a baissé
en moyenne de 20 % et jusqu'à 10 ni
véhicule en moins sur ce boulevard plus
de fluidité et plus d'accessibilité la
lino aurait également favoriser le
développement des quartiers nord de
dijon
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a eu une sorte de
boom économique à la fois que le
développement des zones d'activités
je pense à valmy qui est totalement
maintenant arrivés à maturité mais aussi
une expansion de commerce à bonheur pour
les riverains partagé par les habitants
de toutes ces rues de talent et de
fontaines où les automobilistes passait
à toute heure de la journée pour éviter
les embouteillages en 2015 première
bougie pour la lino et premier bilan
pour la famille laval la situation était
alors quasi idyllique
c'est génial pour moi je suis vraiment
ravi pour garer sa voiture sortir du
stationnement
c'était des fois très difficile parce
que les voitures sur que les sans arrêt
alors que là maintenant là une
circulation beaucoup plus adapté bonjour
allait bien jean-pierre aujourd'hui pour
les habitants de fontaine les dijon les
choses sans avoir bien changé
sur cette route il ya beaucoup plus de
monde que un an après l'ouverture c'est
ça oui enfin pas forcément à tous les
moments bien surtout beaucoup plus de
monde
le soir quand les gens rentrent du
travail et éventuellement le matin quand
ils vont bosser en cause les
embouteillages générés par l'un des
ronds-points de la lino résultat
certains automobilistes délai sa voie
rapide pour des itinéraires bis pense
que si on arrivait à régler le
rond-point la 8 d'une manière un peu
plus logique au niveau du fonctionnement
ça améliorerait nettement la situation
ici oui globalement ça quand même changé
votre quotidien a ému tout à fait tout à
fait à part les quelques heures dont je
viens de parler c'est quand même
nettement favorable pour nous contourner
la lino pour éviter ces embouteillages
le phénomène prend de l'ampleur
les élus la métropole ont bien
conscience de la situation et comme cet
équipement est une route nationale
ils en appellent à l'état qu'il est
temps grand temps que l'état se penche
sur ce problème
dégage des moyens financiers pour
permettre de résoudre ce problème
aujourd'hui dit-il
de savoir à quelle échéance pourrait
intervenir la miss total en deux fois
deux voies de la lino des études
seraient actuellement en cours
en attendant utilisateurs et riverains
devront prendre leur mal en patience
[Musique]